[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to be talking about art
science embroidery and spirituality we
have Laura
Sandusky joining us on the show hello
hello thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me we're really
excited we're also very grateful that we
encountered you and your work with bio
captivate with Lewis Metzger you knew we
loved them very much we're very grateful
to them for making the introduction
happen and we love learning about you at
that bio captivate panel for those that
don't know Laura Tedeschi is an artist
and biochemist
whose primary medium is surface
embroidery and as you can see this
gorgeous
part to her left on your right and yes
you can find her links below
Laura 10 deskey mosaic dot-com also SF
needlework and design org and also at
bio captivate comm as well you can find
that work all those links below and
let's jump into it with one of our
favorite questions to ask to start
things off what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world the direction of
our world I am cautiously optimistic I'm
I see I'm starting to see the reasoning
behind a lot of the conflict as being
fear-based and understanding what that
fear is and and the tribalism I get it
it's like people are worried about not
having resources about and so if we can
address the fear I think things might
get better and and now we all have a
global problem that we can work together
to solve I think that could be
thing it's a scary thing but I think
humans are amazing the creativity the
ingenuity so I do have hope
yeah to come together and solve the
biggest challenges yes so crucial yeah
yeah what do you think are the things
that will help us get there to help
climate change you mean yeah to help us
tackle the big challenges what are the
things I'll help us get there creativity
you know people coming up with with just
these beautiful ideas a lot of
biochemistry a lot of engineering
bacteria had to eat plastic engineering
you know solar all that good stuff how
are we going to get power that isn't
polluting the the atmosphere mm-hmm
yeah okay yeah yeah I think it's doable
I really really do I just I was so
inspired by going to the Kennedy Space
Center and seeing how they got somebody
to the moon with no computers people are
amazing so I just want to UM I mean I
think that people can do it I really can
I really do yeah and the I don't know
there's the phone okay that's all good
don't worry yeah yeah good okay so then
let's jump into journey uh-huh okay yes
we know biotechs such a massive
opportunity for the planet can tackle so
many of the important challenges that we
face she an artist at age five yes and
big influence from mom so start teaching
us about this journey yes my mother was
an artist and highly encouraged a
creativity from from very young and
mandalas especially that's where the
spirituality comes from before I could
talk I think I was I had paper and
crayons and I would start in the middle
and go out and just make mint doll after
mandala and I didn't know what they were
called that at the time it just pleased
me that those patterns and as I grew up
through high school I was my mom taught
me how to embroider and I was very very
young
and it wasn't kids she basically had me
draw and then I would should teach me
stitches and how to turn my pictures
into an embroidery and so I've kind of
always done that I love kits kits are
amazing and they're a great way to learn
and all of that but I use it as a medium
so I've always been one of those kind of
people that has to do art if I don't do
it after a period of time I don't feel
well
so there's a lot there's a lot of us
there's a lot of people like that and so
it just I got really excited about it
it's so meditative and just so you I
love the whole idea of embroidery the
slow art and and I just kept going and
kept going and entered competitions and
all that good stuff so the slow art is
embroidery I like that the slow art
because you're doing stitch by stitch
yes at a time you're making yeah
extremely complex yeah designs like that
and unless you do it on a machine which
is is very doable you design it and put
till a machine to do it it cannot be
done quickly it's there's no physical
possible way to do it quickly quickly
but I like that aspect of it yes so
interesting and sewed them so there are
already potentials to machine to me yes
yes lots of him lots of machine done but
but I I it's very different thing hand
done versus machine yes yes and then
what was it about men dollars that that
because it's all all over your work yeah
yeah yes my main thing mandalas are for
me it when I finally learned what that
term meant somebody said oh that's a
really nice mandala so then then I
started looking it up and figuring it
out it's such a universal symbol of the
circle of life of
just kind of the the it captures the
energy that I feel it exists in in life
you know it's it really is the circle of
life I just look at this and especially
mandalas that have symmetry work for me
you know I just I can't really say why
it just it just that that symbol is you
find it in nature everywhere and I'm
starting to figure out that even though
I thought it was an abstract
representation of life to me it's very
real especially when you go microscopic
macroscopic mandalas everywhere yeah and
it just that formed has just always
excited me I always go back to it yeah
yeah the circle of life yeah yeah now
what was it within this this growing up
being so interested in making your own
art and even having times when you're
like I haven't done in a while I'm gonna
be I have to get back to and do it yeah
that what what was it then that that
kept like what were those most profound
realizations for you along the path of
being an artist as well as then starting
with us becoming a scientist as well
realizations and paths well my mom died
when I was 25 and it was that was a very
profound experience for me and I I took
so much from that experience basically
looking at her life and and and what do
I want my life to be you know and what's
important to me and I I had started
studying science in school a little bit
later actually because I grew up in a
time when girls were not supposed to be
scientists it was quite sexist it was
the 70s 80s you know and and I found out
kind of later so I had to start over in
math and I
it was a little bit of an uphill battle
but I I loved it but I also needed to do
art at the same time and at one point I
was going to just stop doing art and I
stopped doing science and do art
full-time and that didn't work either
and I find that the two of them together
is what fits for me and I've thought a
lot about this and it makes a lot of
sense a lot of people think scientists
are not creative you have to be creative
to be a scientist you have to most of my
colleagues are artists of some force
force or another it would they're
musicians they're painters there
I think athletes are artists in a lot of
ways I mean if you watch a really good
basketball players they're gorgeous the
way they move and that's that's hard you
know so creativity everywhere and you
can't be a good scientist if you're if
you don't have if you don't think of
yourself as creative I think everybody
is creative some people are taught that
they're not and I think that's I don't
like that I think everybody is creative
in their own way they may be better at
one technique or another mm-hmm yeah to
have the full creative expression of
every mind
yes that's unleashed is so crucial yes
so then I'm really happy that you're
starting to you know to get into this
art and science mix but then what was it
that got you into like biochemistry
especially straight yeah I I took all
these all of these tests when I was in I
loved junior college I went to junior
college and it was just a wonderful
experience and they had all these tests
saying we're gonna compare your
personality basically to people who are
happy in their job and when I took that
test way on the happy side was one thing
it said that I should be from my
personality it said I should be a
pharmacist and it that shocked me I'm
like what a pharmacist so I looked into
it and and what it would it entail so
then I went to school and I and I got I
wanted to do the background which was
biochemistry right I didn't want to
go to pharmacy school what you can't
actually you have to do a lot of
background work so I decided to get a
degree in biochemistry and I found that
I loved the research part of it and I
actually did get into pharmacy school I
was there for about a year and found
that I just love the the lab work the
actual discover drug discovery more in
protein chemistry and and physiology
just loved physiology if I if I didn't
go into biochemistry I would have loved
to be a teacher in Physiology it's
fascinating so fascinating how the cell
works all that stuff it's just
fascinating and all of that is an art
math is an art math is beautiful man is
just gorgeous
I don't profess to understand a whole
lot of it but what I do understand I
just love so interesting now there's
also crazy that you had this experience
with your with your mother as well that
yeah that kind of you were able to take
away from such importance of strive as
well and when when when you end up kind
of like figuring out that you are in
love with your both biochemistry as well
as art where did you kind of see
yourself going from there because you
ended up then you spent 20 years at
Chiron and then nine last nine years in
Novartis so how did you end up getting
involved with like the decades of
biochemistry work as well as keeping up
with your art practice right well I got
into Chiron right after pharmacy school
I I decided in the Bay Area there's all
of this biotech which is great and at
that time the work the term biotech was
new it's and and I said okay I'm just
gonna get into a company and and try it
and then go to another company and just
see what it's like you know so I got a
job it was a temporary job at Chiron and
and decided okay if I'll look for
another job someplace else a little bit
later and I never did I was always happy
and I own and I still today if I'm you
know not happy in a job enough to quit
and and look for another job I would do
that but I've been there 30 years so
Chiron was basically bought by Novartis
so I've never left I'm basically a
career 30 yeah Wow
yeah and I've had some just amazing
bosses and it's never boring because
science Tecna and technology changes so
much basically every year I have to
learn new things I get to work with new
people new projects and I'm a protein
biochemist is what I am so and it's just
been very gratifying I learned something
new all the time and so my plan of kind
of job hopping never happens I've just
always been happy and oh man how many
people can say that I am so grateful for
that yeah you know really I've worked
with some beautiful people
Lois Metzger yeah that's where we'll be
friends forever I think and but that's
he was my boss actually yeah so yeah
what's the protein biochemistry what has
been like your most in interesting
insights from from that process to the
last 30 years learning this is this is
actually a big deal learning that
intuition plays a big part in science
especially what I do for for protein
purification so basically we will
express a protein in a Cell say yeast or
e.coli or something like that I have to
break up the break open the cell and
purify that one protein from all the
rest of the proteins so I could do that
a thousand different ways but with
experience and also intuition of the
behavior of the protein which you can
sort of predict but not really just by
seeing how a protein behaves I know if
it's gonna work or not
it's it really is intuitive and people
actually seek me out because I can do
the more difficult proteins that maybe
other people can't do
and I just honor the intuitive basically
artistic creative side of that yeah and
then what was it about when you're when
you're you know after your this process
of doing art in science over 30 years
what was it that got you into in the
embroidery side of things more seriously
yeah yeah okay
well I've always embroidered and and I
did mosaic and and all kinds of things
I've always done some kind of art but
when it was it happened three years ago
I came out basically I it was they call
it an epiphany I I realized oh I'm I'm
really attracted to and love this woman
and that I'd been I thought yeah I
always knew something was different with
me but I didn't know what it was and
then okay that's what it is and then
that was a journey and that was a
difficult journey how long ago was that
that was a little over three years eight
years ago yeah Wow
so and it was always prior to that it
was you thought that it was men that you
were attractive yes I had feelings and
stuff but it was but and this is it this
is basically this is gonna be a very
simple statement but it's a two-year
journey of trying to figure out this
it's not that I'm a lesbian or its I'm
attracted to people people not gender
yeah and it took it it took me a long
time to realize that because when I fell
in love with this woman all the melisma
and hanging out with all the lesbians
I'm like this isn't quite right what's
going on so then I took all the labels
away I took all of that and so I'm
attracted to people yeah and that then I
just kind of okay that is me and then
and then it's been a three year journey
kind of discovering Who I am and what
and so that's when I got really serious
about doing art work and expressing Who
I am
that way not only to say to other people
but also figuring it out for myself
so that's when I started doing a lot of
the pieces that I'm gonna show you today
wow I think so many people fall under
the category of being attracted to
people and that we are just sometimes
put ourselves in such boxes that we kind
of because it's like how much do you
like people do you want to first base
second base
[Laughter]
like 18 years ago I remember seeing a
picture of an advertisement for boys
don't cry I didn't see the movie because
I know it's sad but it was a woman
dressed as a man and I remember the
feeling that I had seeing that it was so
intense and I did not understand it I
tend to like kind of the middle you know
women dressed as men men dressed as
women just the that whole fluid I'm not
bisexual I would say I was pansexual so
it just is so so I pay attention to how
I feel with any particular one yes yes
and then these okay so this is kind of
like this how many years ago was this
with the vehicle that was about I think
I did that two and a half years ago okay
the paint was fading on the car and I
was like okay I could get it painted
blue again or I could do this and I've
wanted to do this since high school yeah
yeah what are unique there's no one else
on the road with that yeah everyone
knows it's you right so everything I
started with mandalas and the words here
can only love others as much as we love
ourselves yeah that is the definition of
love the working definition of love by
brené Brown yes and I made sure I could
had permission to use that as long as I
don't sell anything they said that I can
I can put that on my art yes so it wraps
all the way around and
and it has the whole the whole
definition so things that just you know
this is kind of reminiscent of Tibetan
art so this is about three years ago or
so yeah and it took about a year I would
do this while yeah well I would do it
off and on so like this is one piece and
then I would not do it for awhile or
this this one piece this you could tell
I did that a fourth of July I just loved
dragonflies and just you know yeah whoa
that's soon your pieces like that takes
a long time in there you know like you
said they're so unique and and you can
only love as much as we love ourselves
right so there's these very important
kind of pieces to your essence that
you're embodying in the art that you
make right yeah I used to say that an
ex-girlfriend a hat I can only love you
as much as you love yourself
yes so I'll see you later I miss her so
then the so this also would you call
this also mosaic teach us about what a
mosaic is compared to the embroidery
compared to like what you did on the car
well most the mosaic that I do is actual
tile mosaic has to be tile uh yeah it's
Tessa ray so that's really what mosaic
is so this is a floor I'm sorry Tessa
ray that's what the the little squares
or the little whatever a mosaic is so
it's got I have the the Tessa ray and
then usually um they're not always
growth but um but yeah that's kind of
the definition of a mosaic mosaic it's
almost always tile tile glass glass
porcelain and hatton Tessa rays yes yes
so there's a little differences in the
art of the squares yes the idea yeah
yeah yeah or different shapes and but
you can see the the similarity in my
work more mandalas right put mandalas
yeah almost everything almost everything
but it takes so much time to cut those
and yeah this took two and a half years
but I work full-time so most of my work
you know I'll work on for an hour to an
evening and then if I don't feel like
doing it I won't do it so that's one of
the reasons why it takes so long two and
a half years yeah Wow
yeah but I love meticulous I love you
know I could I do crochet I make lace
and all of that and this is the front
porch and again more more more mandalas
Wow the amount of time that use yeah
yeah invested into yeah the art of the
mosaic the mandala yeah and it's kind of
like a meditative spiritual yes and I
think that's one of the reasons why I
don't feel well if I'm not doing it
because it's a way it really helps me
relax it helps me think you know
oftentimes I will play music and I
remember one piece I did it took me two
years and I played American Idiot by
Green Day over and I think I listened to
that album more than any other album
because it has such beautiful energy and
what's gorgeous oh and I uh yeah so it's
just yeah it's just this I'm just
remembering what it was like listening
to that music and doing that work it's
just wonderful it's healthy for me yeah
the way I would I would yes
describe it so this piece I did this for
a friend of mine he actually is an
artist and he gave me a watercolor of
this so the watercolor was it was a
little bit bigger than this screen and
so I turned it into a little teeny
embroidery and I said to him if you give
me that painting I'll do an embroidery
for you but I get to show it because
it's going to be this
going to be kind of the pinnacle of the
work my work Wow and so that's why this
took me 10 years to do it's done with
really really fine rayon thread on silk
so the blue in the back is silk and it
all has to do with my friend he was a
game man
and he loved flowers and all of that
that's what all of this is about the
rainbow yes he is Native American and
Puerto Rican and but a lot of the work
that he does has has oriental feel just
Japanese Chinese so there's Japanese tea
garden there with the American Indian
and then American Indian the Phoenix
which is Japanese Wow he loves dragons
so that so it's kind of all about him
and then I got my Tibetan stuff in there
now this I did before I had had any
color theory so it was all trial and
error when you're working with color
with this intense blue for example you
put a red next to a blue it turns purple
so I learned so much doing this little
red next to a blue it turns purple yeah
so if you were to put like one single
thread oh next to the blue because it
mixes because it's a single thread yeah
it's a single thread interesting color
theory color theory yeah yes exactly
even a single thread oh yeah and so I
would do it and I'm like that doesn't
look right and I have to rip it out this
is something my mother taught me if you
don't like it rip it up it out cuz at
the very end you're gonna want it
changed
exactly you may as well have it changed
earlier exactly exactly
then in the final product and he said
this was made with some very thin thread
very fine very thin thread yeah now this
piece won Best in Show and the
California State Fair which is a big
deal whoa it's there's ace and 81 county
fairs and then to get into the State
Fair competition at that point there's
like 35 million people in California
yeah so it was a lot of competition and
it was a it was a big deal to and that
made me really happy to win Best in Show
Best in Show State Fair State Fair I got
a little statue of a bear as cool and I
also that also went on tour with the
embroiderers guild for two years in the
United States and Canada which was
amazing it was the 16th it was the 16th
it was a biannual tour and so to get
into that was a very big deal so that's
what I meant when I said you can't have
it for a while so that was that was
basically not true or for me it went on
tour yeah whoa what the embroiderer is
guild yes so they were gonna just when
all of us in Canada that's so neat this
is a really powerful piece yeah yeah
what a cool pinnacle of embroidery and
your essence that you've now gotten to
to share with so many people around the
United States yeah and it comes with so
many cultures like you said - mm-hmm
dragon and Japanese Native American as
well mm-hmm yeah yeah really a melting
pot yeah Wow okay cool so then so then
the the essence of what you know of your
of what you're communicating to with
things like this so this hummingbirds
yes yes so this well especially the
hummingbird actually all right I want to
show you this jacket this is I did for a
friend of mine his name is Craig Rao ski
and he is just a dear friend he's one of
the first people that I came out to and
just really sweet he is a scientist and
an artist active activist he's a hockey
player organizer just on the front lines
and now he's got a startup called
pendulum fishing and doing just
beautiful science so what this is is
basically a a
it's a it's a portrait of how I see
Craig so a abstract portrait so Amendola
so I thought about him when I was
designing I don't actually draw it all
out I'd do it as I go right so I did
this mandala first and it's just I would
think about him and when I stand back
and look at him I'm like yeah that is
Craig and especially this one this one I
had the idea of energy and light so a
light light is a particle and a wave and
so that's where these little stitches
come in I was thinking particle and wave
and experience I really like the idea of
these alternating dark and light they're
called chain stitches and it just right
we just vibrate right try not to cover
your mic oh I'm sorry
thanks Ron and so that is yeah so that's
that's kind of the portrait that I did
for Craig but the first thing he asked
for were these I had them on my jacket
and he has earned these with the
activist activism and Occupy organizers
and he just and he asked for also these
which he probably recognized as an
activist but I decided I wanted to do
them in complementary colors so they
just pop up fight the power
exactly so I really would like when when
he's in he'll get up there again with
the bullhorn right I'd love for him to
wear this and stand back I'm doing
science I guess but I was going to talk
about the hummingbird he was the one who
asked for a hummingbird Wow a
hummingbird is a symbol of communication
and just being a hundred percent present
for example we're talking right now and
I will I am striving to be here a
hundred times whistling and right and so
that is the idea there and
the four four quarters north north east
south and west is what the idea there
and I thought so long how I was going to
do it and the sketch of the bird
actually just took maybe 10 seconds and
I loved how it turned out and so I've
been doing more of them that's what that
is I have them on my jet on my jacket I
do love the way that you will have the
sketch of it is is really strong and
it's quite it makes it quite easy to
actually embroider when one of the wings
is out yeah it kind of looks like
potentially bolt but then the tail the
sound you know the body it's all kind of
you see half it's a half yeah but
actually bird the hummingbirds don't do
this that's not a position I warned the
other way it's kind of Egyptian it's the
way it's kind of Egyptian yeah and so I
like it it's it's very much a symbol the
other thing that I did for Craig and he
asked for was the elephant and which
stands for wisdom okay and he and this
is actually the first I would call them
spirit animals I've done a number of
different things but it's kind of this
style so this is an actual elephant a
mama elephant that I got off the
internet it's just an outline her
outline okay and and I the the little
nick in the ear was was just a shadow
but I liked it it gave her character oh
I see you know it's so small
yeah but I just a little nick and i have
another one it was character yeah and he
wanted to wear this he took a trip to
india and he wanted to wear this so i
had a deadline out that was a yes but so
that's that's for craig and go much on
even just one jacket yes but he means so
he's such an inspiration for me and he's
so dear to me and it means the world to
me to give this as a gift
and so but I get to again I was able to
bring it here I went and said hey I'm
gonna do this I need the jack back also
but yeah so that's that's kind of where
the idea of this comes from this thread
here
glow-in-the-dark mm-hmm oh it is it's
glow-in-the-dark fun is that yeah what
is that
so this was a sample it's basically part
of a challenge for the San Francisco
School of needlework and design which I
discovered about a year ago
fairly new school somebody told me about
it I went and checked it out and that's
beautiful it's amazing it's in San
Francisco on Union Square wow they have
well over 3,000 books that are available
to anybody to look at you can't take it
with you but the place is open you can
go and check it out beautiful classes
its nonprofit you can be a brand new
beginner never picked up needles or or
designers go there people have been
doing this for years and years and years
the founders went to the Royal
needlework School in London yep and then
they came here decided to start
something similar here in San Francisco
yeah the Royal music yeah they do all
the Royal stuff all those wedding
dresses and the coronation and all of
that yeah it's it's yeah it's pretty
well but it's it's a beautiful school
and I'm so happy to be associated with
them now I'm now a guest teacher there I
love that I'm so excited
yeah guess teaching yeah will work yeah
yeah whoa this is a piece I did for
Kelly Paschal Hunter so I was wearing
some of my embroidery and we I was
standing in line for taco and she saw it
and decided she said I have to have that
jacket and so we we started talking and
turned out that she had a gallery just
across the street from where we were in
downtown Oakland talking talking and
talking and
and we decided that it would be fun to
have me sit in the gallery and actually
work and I said I would do this jacket
for her so this is hers so I did this
piece in her gallery which was really
kind of fun because people would come in
especially kids who have never seen
anybody embroider before they could see
me in there doing it and so it was
basically like a live exhibit oh yeah it
was so fun and after a while I brought
equipment so people could have a hand at
it I taught him it's a stitch or two and
it was fun but I think that's where I
got the teaching bug yeah yeah yeah
there's a live exhibit you're gonna yeah
it's you what you said about kids is
interesting to me because we have a
quite a in many ways when children are
born in Metropolis is they don't
necessarily get the opportunity to look
up at the Milky Way so when you when you
we just see clothing and just you can
buy it at a store we don't actually see
people doing embroidery work and we
don't actually know about the con that
it was used for it right so it's
important to like dive into double-click
into what a cloak what a piece of
clothing even is and how it got there
mm-hmm yep yep yep yeah absolutely
so then this one image 10 okay okay this
is this is on a previous jacket that I
had this is when I was coming out and I
did a scientist so I did a lot of
research well what is it to be part of
the lgbtq+ community right what is this
what is the rainbow flag mean and so
Gilbert Baker designed it at the request
of Harvey Milk and so this is what the
colors mean
serenity life healing son nature art
harmony and spirit yeah and I just love
that yeah and I actually have a little
story about when I first was coming out
I was it's a scary thing it just is
especially when I started doing research
and seeing
the the oppression and and it can be
very dangerous
to be LGBT in some parts of the
community I have never had a problem
here because we live in the Bay Area
it's wonderful but I was I went for a
walk and I saw in my neighborhood
somebody had a rainbow flag and I can't
tell you I didn't know who they were it
just made me it just this glowing right
here I felt welcome yeah yeah so I
actually wrote them a note and told them
a little bit my story and and so the
rainbow flag actually means a lot to me
for that reason we became friends and
you know and then I find out there's
just this huge community where I live I
didn't even know it yes so no one the
ability for us to provide space and time
for those that want to express
themselves and in a way that is
open-minded and loving and caring is
critical critical mmm-hmm
so then how about I'm so so interested
in and of course just so many questions
about the actual art and science and
spiritual processes that that are
happening here we have a couple more
images to show Jill that came in
something happen with this hold on noise
11 is what is this five it's enough it's
five
what do you call those it's a those are
mandalas as well oh yeah five mandalas
yeah that's a sampler that I did for the
San Francisco School need a working
design they have an advanced program for
surface embroidery and they asked if I
would do a sampler in my style so of
course they're mandalas Hey and each
circle is a different type of super
simple nor is this the next half there
we go North problem so they asked me to
do this and so there's just different
different stitches different so this
this particular one is basically all
knots so and this one is composite so
there's different kinds of so it's it's
so you would be amazed how many stitches
they're hard yeah to this one these are
called complex and so you can see
they're they're kind of woven this is
you know fuzzy these come come out
they're there oh they have a little bit
of a three-dimensional 3d exactly right
these are all filling stitches and these
are all line stitches oh my gosh so
there's like so much so so some so some
of the stitches are you kind of have a
little bit of is it like excess material
so that you can also like push it in a
certain way so it can be like seeing
create kind of this this sort of oh did
you stitch it in and how and then you
have a little bit of extra so you can I
kind of like yeah well this is actually
one of my very favorite stitches this is
called a fly stitch Y space and what I
like about it you'll see you see it a
lot in my work all it is is you come up
you come down and then you do a little
anchor stitch above yeah it's it's a
there too then yeah it's pretty simple
but I love the the way the light catches
and it's got a lot of movement the
hummingbird wings are done with this
stitch here
yes yeah oh the chain stick this is a
chain stitch one of my very favorite
stitches and it's because I like to
think of what that stitching means to me
it's a chain it's this you know how
we're all linked together yeah so
especially when I do these background
patterns which I love that's what I
think about when I'm doing it and I do a
lot of lettering and often I use the
chain stitch for that and I like to
write in cursive yeah we just saw yeah
yeah I like down here down there - yeah
that's all change ditch - yeah and I
have another Wow there's so many
differences yeah I'm so happy that even
the start of the breakdown of the
different embroidery tactics what do you
call me an embroidery style
you mean like surface embroidery is a
like yeah well there's that breakdown
and yeah there's the breakdown of the
types of types of stitches types yeah so
this is a filling stitch this is a
composite stitch that's a knot stitch so
that's just a type of stitch okay yeah
yeah I mean books they're all broken
down yeah okay there's types of stitches
and then there's places to embroider and
this is surface embroidery yes and what
are the other embroideries just as an
example yeah there would be gold work so
like a lot of the the coronation stuff
you'll see all of this really shiny gold
work like a crown that comes out or on
Game of Thrones the embroidery of Game
of Thrones is this gorgeous a lot of
gold work there you have cross stitch
you have knotted stitch there's
something called white work and black
work there's all of these things some of
them I never even heard of before yes I
thought I did embroidery I do one kind
embroidery with a bunch of different
stitch type yes these are all chain
stitches these are chain stitches and
this particular design I just did I'm
going to be teaching a class every
Thursday
at seven o'clock at counterculture labs
oh sweet called bio embroidery bio
embroidery how fun is that yeah
somewhere I learned to do PCR oh yeah oh
it's so much fun well Mario had the idea
to do a mash-up of embroidery and
science and I thought that was great so
this is the first design that I came up
with I looked at a bunch of oh yeah so
this is the carbon they're gonna start
with this well yes it's very very casual
so this is available if people want
people can bring whatever you know
whatever they want to do and we're
encouraging to embroider on clothes so
if they if especially if they have
experience they can they can do whatever
design they want but I'm gonna have a
bunch of design tools and everything and
I'll be there basically just to help
there's a lot of creative people out
there so this is this is available if
somebody wants to do this absolutely but
certainly don't have to yeah it's gonna
be very casual so every yeah every month
we're gonna get together just you know
at 7 o'clock and have a good time
everything's been donated by the San
Francisco School of needlework and
design it's so nice of them to it is so
as a nonprofit or donating for the bio
embroidery class yes Monica Labs you're
doing it once a month once a month okay
on Thursday on Thursday at 7 o'clock
there's this early space at the Omni
space over in the East Bay
in Oakland yeah so for those that are
local and interested yeah and the first
one is this Thursday I'm really excited
nice yeah it's gonna be fun and actually
the next design is another one that I
came up with for them and this is in
chain stitch it's in glow-in-the-dark
thread and this is the molecular
structure of psilocybin
so and I have its glow in the dark so
that's funny people can walk around at
that but I also have structures for ATP
or all kinds of different chemical
structures are huge ones but what fun
way to like increase people's awareness
yeah that's the idea
yeah yes that's idea of kind of like a
lot of the work in general yes yes yes
yes yeah and actually if I could get
into we talked a little bit about what
is art and what is art to me yes please
so back when I was 20 I thought art has
to be in a frame and hanging our wall
and being in a museum and it really it
doesn't I learned so I did a bunch of
pieces in frames and they're good
they're very pretty but they're there
there's a distance to them they don't
they have a one dimension ality as I
look at them when I look at the work
that I've done on clothes those have
real spirit you know so what I like
especially about embroidering clothes or
even doing things doing work on the car
or something that's going to be actually
be seen you can communicate what you
want to communicate it's so cool art to
me is community is about communication
100% you know whatever it is you want to
communicate if it's something oh this is
this is beautiful that's what you want
to communicate that this whatever it is
it's beautiful
oftentimes I'm communicating this is who
I am that's been my journey for the last
three years figuring out a figuring out
who I am and presenting that to the
world this is who I am if we were to go
over one of the jackets that I brought
or even this you'd learn a lot about me
yeah yeah so I don't know yes but just
even quickly holy cow that's so cool
that yeah you're just trapped Art's
trapped in a museum people have to Co go
to it and look at it versus if you're
wearing the art if you're driving the
art yeah you're like in you're
communicating spirituality or or love
right all these different
a critical pieces to our cohesion our
social fabric I think that's an
excellent way of describing what you're
just passionate about it hopefully that
we can get other people excited I hope
so let's hit it
this I did this maybe two years ago I
was really in the middle of it
I was having a dream and I dreamt that
the person that I was living with at the
time had invited into our house a
mountain lion well and the mountain lion
was sitting on the back of the couch
like this big mountain lion just kind of
half eyes half closed
you know just resting the way cats do
you know and I was looking at this
mountain lion thinking he's crazy
this mountain lion could kill me I mean
why would he invite this mountain lion
into our house and yet I wasn't afraid
of it and it was very I didn't
understand the dream but it was very I
don't know it made me feel good so I
have a wonderful therapist that I've
been talking to through this whole
journey and she said that oftentimes in
dreams whatever you're dreaming about is
you represents you interesting and I
thought about that and I'm like wow I
love that idea because mountain lions
are they they waste nothing they are
just this so powerful they can take care
of themselves and yet they're very
loving and very kind they aren't as
solitary as you might think they
actually do help each other and when I
thought about that it gave me a little
it empowered me a bit and I really liked
that idea and so I had the idea to do
kind of a spirit mountain lion that's
what this is but you know most you'll
never find a blue-eyed mountain lion oh
that's so cool I have blue eyes so I
decided to make it blue I know blue-eyed
mountain lions
no no bro Brown Oh bro yeah they're
absolutely gorgeous but that's why the
eyes are blue oh I'm so sorry about the
phone you're good
again the hummingbird is about
communication the the the mandala that's
around here is very delicate it's just I
wanted to give a sense of how kind of
complex and delicate the human spirit is
yeah and then around here I decided I
kind of I've I'm not shy anymore but I
was and I just I wanted to light a fire
and so what this is actually is the
pansexual flag okay that's what this is
okay and these colors behind it are fire
oh whoa so I want it to light the fire
cool get that so look at how much
meaning there is in the yeah there's so
much representation yeah and even if you
look at that and you don't know that's
what it means you can I would imagine
you can look at it and feel that that
symbolism is is there yeah right yeah
right so that I love doing that that's
so well done yeah thank you yeah thank
you
yeah it's just oh I just love doing it
do you have a do you have any feeling
about the commercialization of art and
embroidery to the point where it can
potentially more and more people can
wear things like that maybe rather than
a piece of clothing that is from one of
the major retailers or something like
that you mean doing it themselves or
we're just even like the
commercialization of it by Machine or
etc just to be able to get more people
being like wow that's you said that take
this yeah I love actually the idea of
taking a design and putting it to
machine and maybe not absolutely mass
producing it but or even mass producing
it and and and making art making your
clothing a statement yes yes a lot like
a
- yeah that's how I think it's likewise
yes and so I would love to see that and
have more more artistic value that you
can you can bring to your clothes yes
you know yeah the clothing is a
statement yeah yeah yeah yeah it really
is
you've been trying to help shift the
tide away from suit coats and heels and
makeup yeah - let's have fun let's
represent ourselves with peace unity
love all the spirituality or whatever
represents it represents you yeah yeah
yeah yeah I used to wear you know we
don't want to know what Ron would be
aware yeah yeah I used to wear
sweatpants and t-shirts to work and and
now I really do kind of present myself
the way more authentically yeah yeah
yeah so um will you give us the sort of
the grand like give us the grand thesis
between the art and the science you'll
growing up and doing all the embroidery
and then the art and the biochemistry
but then the communicative side of all
of this and the spiritual side of all of
this what is yeah what is this grand
thesis well I think that the the the
intersection again of art and science
and and understanding that we don't need
to be pigeonholed scientists don't need
to say okay I'm a scientist therefore
I'm not creative I have to just do this
or you know I love the idea of bringing
maybe artists and and the artist side
into the scientific world and creating a
different vocabulary you know
yeah so that right there is so much even
just that yeah yeah should just create
it and and and think it's all about
thinking about outside the box
especially or you need to be creative as
a scientist yeah yeah yeah even for the
artist to think scientifically as well
it's interesting for both sides yeah
exactly right
have you heard anti disciplinarian yet
no anti disciplinary I thought that was
so interesting I think I think what it
means is that you're taking something
like biochemistry and you're saying okay
well block Sheen has nothing good art
has nothing to do with biochemistry so
basically it's like how can we take the
subjects that have nothing to do with
the field right and bring them into the
field I realize holy cow there's
actually so in so many interesting
things to do oh I like that too I like
that a lot and I think that's a big
thesis of ours as well as bio captivates
the big push for the science and art to
live with interplay more interplay right
okay cool very cool
yeah all right thank you for yes there's
okay couple last questions on the way
out okay
well quickly can anyone how can someone
access the the they can go to here in
the Bay Area they can go to the the SF
San Francisco School of needlework and
design who would need a work in design
they can find their local needlework
locations they can play that way but
then can anyone also like reach out can
anyone order pieces from you are you
doing that as well
I actually don't sell and the reason why
is the the time-consuming foot so I I
didn't show this piece but this I've
been working on for about a year and
it's so involved I literally would
charge probably 20k I would 20 yes and
all because because of its kind of like
Couture it is price it totally yeah
because of hundreds of hours yes yes yes
yes so I honestly don't sell I would
entertain a commission but it would
likely not you know I I actually I'm
working right now for for a friend of
mine who is amazing you met them Fang
yeah and I'm doing a piece right now for
them it's it's a military jacket that is
all about Emperor Norton and they are
actually going to be in a show Taylor
max show which is 24 it's a 24 decade
history of popular music well and it's
going to it's a pure surprise nominated
show it's phenomenal show things gonna
be it in in Berlin and so I'm gonna
finish that jacket by October whoa
so I'm so excited pieces like that's a
gift that is not twenty four decades
you're gonna put that on twenty four
decades of the popular music it's the
name of the show right but the jacket
that I'm making for Fang is is all about
Emperor Norton and so it'll be ignored
Emperor Norton which is a local
character here in San Francisco
okay and so yeah up Google Emperor
Norton I'm a big that's actually what
I'm wearing right now is an emperor
Norton or if I turn around if you can
see it can you see that yes okay so
that's Emperor Norton I am a big huge
fan of Emperor Norton if anybody should
be famous
except for Norton okay okay the last
couple questions we have all right are
we alone in the cosmos I don't think so
we can't be we can't be I think that we
are there's so much out there that's
where spirituality comes for me is
there's there's so much that my animal
brain cannot comprehend that I just
don't believe that it's not there I
really you know even even on a different
plane or in a different you
that we just can't perceive our
perception is so limited in the in a you
know so no short answer is no and I know
what about do you think we're in a
simulation that's interesting the older
I get the more I think that might be pop
possible yeah and when when like the
matrix first came out I'm like that's
crazy and the more the older I get and
like that could be and then what about
what do you think the most beautiful
thing in the world
oh oh so much I don't know if I could
pick one beautiful thing there's just so
much beauty I mean
you know even it could be even be a if I
was just thinking about this on the way
over I was talking to you about Fang at
one point Fang was walking towards me
and and what I just struck me as being
so beautiful
I literally could not breathe I've never
swoons like that before I could not
breathe and it was a and it was just
that beauty and and the beauty is is
also that feeling that I felt beauty is
perception I think so I I really
couldn't nail it down but so much I look
at Apple telescope pictures those are
stunningly beautiful and I look at
electron micrographs of protein I think
crystal structures of viruses are so
gorgeous they're beautiful mandalas whoa
gorgeous you know if I had to pick
something I would say mandalas pretty
much of every you know even natural even
yeah there's something called a cyma
scope which I just discovered basically
they take sound they'll play a note have
you have you heard of it cymatics
yes I'm addicts and a Simas go pool so
they they can see the wave patterns in
water of the different notes so there I
mean I've literally made those mandalas
literally before you know and and it
really struck me those are so gorgeous
beautifully symmetric going mmm yeah I
could go on and on probably for 24 hours
of all the things I find such a pleasure
thank you your work over the last thirty
years both in biochemistry but also an
art and embroidery and it's just
mind-blowing you come to what you're
communicating through it how you take it
mobile yeah that's really interesting
and I really appreciate thank you so
much thank you thank you I appreciate it
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode we encourage you
to check out the links below to Loret
and Eskimos a accom also the SF
needlework in design org and bio
captivate comm and go to your own local
needlework and design locations and go
and play with yourself with things like
embroidery talk more about them the
blend between science and art and their
interplay with your friends your
co-workers online on social media just
get talking more about it mixing these
disciplines together huge shout-outs
around Vegas thank you very much for
producing and directing and support the
artists and entrepreneurs and
organizations around the world that you
believe in support simulation our links
are below help us scale and grow and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world thank you so
much for tuning in and we will see you
soon
that's it
[Music]